all tomorrows a billion year chronicle
of the myriad species and mixed fortunes
of man
long ago in the distant past humans
colonized mars
it took centuries to terraform the red
planet
first they made oceans using the water
from comets
then they sent microbes to create
breathable air then
introduced genetically modified plants
and animals
it was only after mars was transformed
into a habitable world
that the first people came to mars in
colony ships
so the first steps on mars were taken
not by astronauts
but by barefoot children on lush green
grass
the people of mars developed their own
culture and identity
separate to earth the low gravity made
martians tall
and spindly and they became almost a
different species to the earthlings
for hundreds of years the two planets
co-existed
but as mars started to surpass earth
tensions led to war
interplanetary war wasn't glorious or
exciting
there were no heroic pilots or massive
spaceships
the war was fought by complicated
automated machines
in a slow strategic nerve-wracking
contest that
caused unimaginable destruction billions
of people died in the war
and humans almost went extinct so the
survivors of earth and mars
united and made a plan to ensure this
would never
happen again humanity made massive
reforms
to their politics and economics and they
changed themselves
they genetically modified humanity into
a new subspecies called the star people
made to be better and smarter and
adapted to expand into space
and it worked within a few generations
the unified star people
peacefully colonized the solar system
other stars were too
far away to fly to in person so instead
the star people sent out
automated machines that would fly to
distant worlds
and terraform them then use genetic
material to create people to live there
there was a weird problem with these
colonies where many humans fell in love
with the machines that had created them
and died in mass identity crises
but the colonies that survived thrived
and expanded across the galaxy
starting a golden age for humanity
trillions of people lived peaceful
utopic lives
their worlds united by communication
across
centuries of light as the star people
explored space they discovered some
alien creatures
but didn't find any intelligent life so
they wondered were humans
alone in the galaxy on one alien world
they found a fossil of a bird-like
creature that didn't seem related to the
other native life
the native creatures had three limbs and
copper bones but
this bird had four limbs and calcium
bones it seemed related to an extinct
dinosaur from
earth so how the hell did this extinct
earth animal end up on this distant
alien world some people thought god must
have done it and there was a resurgence
of religion
but others thought aliens did it that
there must be some civilization out
there who had
space flight and bioengineering millions
of years before humans even had
fire humanity hoped that these aliens
would be peaceful
but just in case they built weapons to
defend themselves
weapons so powerful they could
obliterate stars
but all of that was useless in the end
humanity was attacked by a godlike
ancient species called
the q they were galactic nomads who
constantly migrated through space
and they had a fanatical religious
mission to remake the
universe using genetic manipulation
so when the q found humans they didn't
see them
as people they were just objects to be
changed into whatever shape
the queue wanted within a thousand years
the queue destroyed human civilization
but some human species lived on
because the queue used their
bioengineering technology
to reshape humanity into thousands of
bizarre
sub-species they made humans into tools
into pets into wild animals they ruled
over the human worlds for 40 million
years
and then they [ __ ] off to find their
next victims
leaving humanity divided and
differentiated
beyond recognition these twisted species
were the last remnants of humanity
on one world where the husks of dead
cities
baked under a scorching sun lived the
worms
they were humans but the q had modified
their hands and feet into
tiny feeble appendages reduced their
eyes to pinpricks
and removed most of their brain all
their lives the worms
dug aimlessly through the ground if they
found
food they ate it if they found other
worms they
sometimes ate them or reproduced
they were wretched mindless creatures
but their humanity would eventually
resurface
on another world were the titans who
roamed a vast savannah
their hands were clumsy stumps but their
lower lip was like the trunk of an
elephant
and could be used like a hand they were
some of the smartest of the new human
species and gradually they
achieved sentience they built homes
agriculture
language literature made ornate wood
carvings
in booming voices they told myths and
legends of the bygone half-remembered
past
with enough time these titans could have
started a new humanity
but an ice age hit the planet and these
gentle giants disappeared
forever on other worlds humans had been
twisted into predators
looking like vampires and werewolves of
myth
with sharp claws and killing teeth
their prey were also human made into
herbivores with bird-like
feet the prey had the dull minds of
animals but the predators
on the hunt kept some spark of human
intelligence
which would eventually re-emerge
the mantalopes were bred to be singers
and memory retainers for the queue
so they had fully human minds they
understood the world around them
but in the bodies of grazing heard
animals they were powerless to change
anything
so for centuries mournful herds roamed
the plains singing songs of desperation
and loss they created whole religions
and oral traditions around their grief
and frustration
until gradually mercifully their agony
faded because evolutionarily a
stupid simple-minded mantelope survives
as well or better than a conscious sad
mantelope
so within a hundred thousand years this
melancholy world
fell silent human minds aren't sacred to
evolution
and soon only animals remained
the lizard herders were the lucky ones
because the cue
wiped out their intelligence and stunted
their brains so that they could never
regain
sentience so they didn't suffer like the
manta lopes did
the lizard herders survived in symbiosis
with some herbivorous reptiles
and while the lizard herders stayed
simple-minded the reptiles
evolved slowly growing stronger and
smarter
the queue twisted humanity into a
variety of
aquatic creatures there were limbless
eel people
and whale-like behemoths and horrifying
multitudes of brainless wallowers that
served as
food stock most of them went extinct
when the queue left
but the swimmers survived feeding on
fish and crustaceans in their world's
oceans
they didn't look much like humans but
human eyes peered through
their blubbery eyelids and they spoke to
each other
though underwater they couldn't hear
each other's words
the tempters were so [ __ ] up it's a
wonder they survived it all
the queue made them into bizarre living
decorations
two meter tall cones of flesh like
grotesque carnivorous plants
those were the females the males were
mindless little monkey imp creatures who
blindly served their queen
controlled by vocal and pheromonal
signals
they'd gather the food and guard their
queen and occasionally they would mate
by descending into this breeding tube
like a subway commuter
it was weird but it worked and the
tempters
mound forests spread across their world
they could have built some kind of
civilization
but they were obliterated by a stray
comet
and one of humanity's best and weirdest
hopes
died out the bone crushers looked like
monsters like giants or ogres with
beaks derived from teeth they only ate
putrefying meat and they communicated by
defecating on each other
but they were actually pretty successful
they reached a medieval level of
civilization
until they ran out of rotting meat to
eat
and eventually collapsed when the queue
attacked
most human worlds were quickly defeated
but
one world fought back resisting the
queue two times before falling
the queue punished and humiliated this
world for its resistance
by making them into the colonials
the colonials were disembodied cultures
of
skin connected with a network of basic
nerves
the q used them as living filtering
devices
living off cue waste products and for no
other reason than to make the colonials
suffer the cue left them
with their consciousness and their eyes
so that they could fully witness
their own wretched fate for
40 million years the colonials suffered
generations of misery
hoping for their own extinction but they
were made to be efficient
and so they spread across the planet in
quilt-like
fields of human flesh the q made lots of
flying human species some like bats or
pterosaurs
others like angels or demons dancing
through the ether
or strange ugly creatures that floated
on glands full of gas
one species called the flyers had a
special starfish-shaped heart that
processed oxygen so efficiently
that they had enough energy to support
flight as well as
human-like brains other flying species
weren't so lucky the hand flappers had
wings that were useless for flying
but also couldn't be used as hands all
they could do
was flap about to display their sexual
availability
and so they ecstatically flashed and
danced their way to
extinction some humans tried to escape
the queue by hiding underground
the q found them anyway and made them
into
subterranean mousy morlock people called
the blind folk
they used whiskers and long fingers and
big ears
and banshee-like screams to navigate
in the dark they lived off fungi and
fish
and avoided predation by bats and
crocodilian creatures
these albino trogdolites looked fairly
human
but where their eyes should have been
there was nothing but a haunting
smooth skin eventually the movement of
tectonic plates
crushed these underground habitats one
by one
on a planet with extremely high gravity
the q
made the lopsiders flat deformed
asymmetrical creatures right out of the
fever dreams of picasso
dali or bosh the lopsiders crawled along
the ground on three hands
with another limb used as an antenna
one eye stared straight up while the
other eye
scanned ahead as wretched as they looked
the lopsiders
thrived on their heavy world they
domesticated some native creatures
and began the long road to civilization
on a moon with very low gravity the q
made the striders enormously tall
thin creatures who walked among huge
trees that towered like skyscrapers
the striders were very delicate so even
with low gravity a fall could shatter
their bones
the striders were eventually wiped out
by a bunch of chickens who
over 2 million years evolved into deadly
predators
on another world where the humans
temporarily resisted the queue
the queue punished the humans by
creating an array of parasites
who were also made from humans there
were
tortoise-sized vampire-like ambulatory
parasites
and smaller parasites that lived
attached to their hosts
there was even one horrific parasite
that infested the wombs of its victims
many of these parasite life cycles were
so elaborate and baroque that they went
extinct as soon as the queue left
but some of the parasites survived and
developed a symbiosis that benefited
their hosts as well as themselves
one human species evolved on a world of
great archipelagos
calm shallow oceans sprinkled with
countless islands
the finger fishers evolved to catch fish
with their long
fingers adapted into fish hooks and ate
them with long
snouts full of needle-sharp teeth and
their evolution would get
even weirder later on the hedonists were
created by the queue to be their
pampered pets living carefree lives of
pleasure
their world was a tropical paradise of
succulent fruits
and lakes of sweet bacterial juice
they were the only animals on their
planet and had no predators or
competition to deal with
under normal conditions this might lead
to overpopulation
but the queue designed the hedonists to
only get pregnant
after mating an enormous number of times
so the population was stable and the
hedonists filled their
lives with eating sleeping and
mind-blowing sex
their minds were blissfully empty
because
who needed to think when they're having
such a good time
the insect offer guy adapted to eat
insects
they had claw-like hands to dig long
tongues to scoop up bugs
and leathery faces to protect from bites
they lived quiet unnoticed lives on
their
obscure world but little did they know
they would play
a key role in the fate of humanity
when the queue attacked not all humans
were captured
some of them escaped into space and
built homes inside hollowed-out
asteroids
they adapted to zero gravity by growing
long
spindly limbs and pressurized digestive
systems so they could move around in
space by
farting from their highly evolved
sphincters
these spaces changed to the point where
they could never return to a planet with
gravity
but they didn't care they were
comfortable in their weightless void
worlds
and paid little attention to their human
relatives
on the planets below so across the
galaxy
these twisted post-human species
struggled to survive
they evolved diversified rose and fell
and most of them died out without the
universe
ever knowing they existed which is
normal
extinction is just as natural as
speciation
and for each species that died out new
ones evolved to take their place
generating an ever-changing
kaleidoscopic variety
of life-forms and from this endless
churn of
life and death some species rose up to
achieve new kinds of sentience and
civilization like stars
emerging from a dark fog the scorching
hot planet of the worms eventually
cooled down
and life emerged onto the surface the
worms
filled new ecological niches evolving
into serpentine grazers swimmers
predators
and eventually people with human-like
intelligence
the snake people had unique
spiral-shaped brains that allowed them
to observe and understand their world
they developed
a hand derived from their ancestors feet
and they built vast cities of tightly
intertwined tunnels
and homes they enjoyed books
and music played as vibrations in the
ground
the snake people may have looked alien
but
their daily lives were full of joys and
sorrows
hopes and dreams humanity
the predators evolved into the killer
folk
their deadly claws became grasping hands
and their saber teeth receded into
organs of social display
killer folk society was built around
hunting and violence
and so their history was filled with war
for thousands of years nomadic warriors
with vast herds of
once human livestock battled each other
across a chessboard of continents
so their world is an archaeologist's
dream
rich with the ruins of fallen kingdoms
but one faction of killer folk developed
factory
farming and rejected their violent past
for a more
peaceful unified future some
conservative factions kept to the old
way
fanatically devoted to traditional
warfare and hunting
these two factions came dangerously
close to global conflict
but the killer folk managed to reconcile
and survive
underwater the swimmers couldn't make
fire
so they made a different kind of
technology
they learned to breed their tools and
machines
the tool breeders domesticated and
modified other sea creatures
and built entire cities powered by
organic life
huge heart-like creatures pumped
nutritious fluids through a network of
self-healing conduits
like a living power grid the breeders
homes were made from
living shell and bone with
bioluminescent lights
they had televisions derived from
cephalopod skin
medicinal sea squirts weapons made from
mollusks that fired teeth as ammunition
with genetic modification stem cells and
tissue cultures
the tool breeders mastered the oceans
and
even the small landmasses of their world
but they weren't content with just one
planet
the tool breeders grew living spaceships
and reached for the stars the lizard
herders were stunted
and never achieved sentience but the
lizards
thrived and eventually built
civilizations
using the humans for transport labor
and food these lizards had no biological
connection to humanity
but they took on a human-like cultural
identity
because they were influenced by the
ruins of the star people on their world
they realized what the queue had done to
the humans
and feared that if the queue returned
they might suffer the same
fate for millions of years the colonials
were helpless fields of flesh carpeting
the shores of their world like algae
but they were resilient and eventually
they
organized themselves evolving from a
homogeneous mass
into differentiated colonies each cell
specialized to perform different
functions for the colony
and the colonies started competing
against each other
some colonies grew tap roots to siphon
resources from afar
or starfish-like feet to move around
or claws and poisons to attack other
colonies
the winner of this evolutionary arms
race was an intelligent colony called
the modular people in their vast
industrial megalopolis the people took a
wide variety of shapes and sizes
they could combine themselves or split
apart or
exchange parts all interchangeable cells
playing a role in one great organism
so the modular people achieved the
impossible
turning their miserable existence into a
utopia
where billions lived happy lives as part
of the unified whole
the flyers diversified into many
different species
as predators herbivores even swimmers
one species were like stalks who waded
through swamps to catch
their prey their versatile feet which
had evolved to catch slippery fish
became articulate hands as they
developed intelligence and society
since these ptero sapiens could fly they
had a global mindset
borders and nations made no sense when
it was so easy to travel freely
people and ideas spread quickly across
their planet
and they built an egalitarian society
without strict social classes
they built cities of perches and fluting
towers
harnessed nuclear power and farmed their
relatives on the ground for food
though their civilization thrived their
bodies
struggled to support their highly
developed brains and their power of
flight
so the pterosans usually died by the age
of 23.
keenly aware of their mortality they
appreciated
every moment of their lives their
philosophers
pondered the meaning of life with
feverish intensity
rapidly filling libraries with their
tomes
the terra sapien in this picture poses
at
a seaside resort this 10-day vacation
was the only holiday in her short life
despite the crushing gravity of their
world the lopsiders built an advanced
civilization
their pancake flat buildings spread all
over their world
and they developed space flight so that
they could escape their planet
and its oppressive gravity to adapt to
life
on new worlds they engineered a
subspecies of themselves who could live
in low gravity
called the asymmetric people the
asymmetric people
thrived in the freedom of new worlds
but they had no love for their creators
the asymmetric people ruthlessly
exterminated the lopsiders on their
homeworld
and went on to explore the heavens alone
the parasites and their hosts evolved
symbiotic relationships
like some parasites used sharp sensors
to warn their hosts of predators
or provide weapons like venom for
defense
in return the hosts provided their
nutritious blood
and developed specialized nesting sites
on their bodies for the parasite to
attach to
rich with blood vessels and protective
fur
the parasites and hosts became
inextricably linked
almost like they were one being at first
the hosts were like horses being
steered and influenced by the parasites
but eventually they became
no more than puppets totally controlled
by the parasites through tactile
and olfactory signals the intelligent
parasite civilization
eventually developed technology that
replaced the need for hosts
but they kept the hosts around for
tradition and convenience
an average symbiote might start the day
in a business host
and then change to a comfortable
domestic host at home
after work the world of the finger
fishes
was full of scattered isolated islands
so like the galapagos or madagascar on
earth
these islands were a seething
evolutionary cauldron that gave rise to
wildly diverse species
one line of finger fishes evolved into
the sail people
their long fingers evolved into sails
that could drive them effortlessly
across
oceans they used their tongues to catch
prey
and eventually their tongues split and
articulated to be used as hands
the sail people needed strong memories
to navigate the oceans and locate prey
so naturally they soon evolved
intelligence
it took a long time to develop social
and political stability
because their scattered and diverse
world gave rise to a huge variety of
creatures who fiercely competed
for generations flotillas of tribal
warriors and pirate societies battled
in epoch spanning conflicts until
finally one
group of sail people became powerful
enough to finally
unify their world and make peace
blood had stained the oceans for too
long
the peaceful paradise of the hedonists
seemed like it would never
end but over millions of years
nothing lasts forever geologic activity
threw up clouds of dust that blocked the
sun
and killed most of the hedonists only a
small
mutant subset survived by escaping the
reproductive limits of their ancestors
these satiriacs got their [ __ ] together
and built
an advanced self-sustaining civilization
but there were still traces of their
hedonistic
past remaining in their genes so their
societies retained a delightful streak
of pleasure seeking and promiscuity
festivals concerts and ritualized orgies
punctuated every
working wake and now that pleasure was
savored
by sentient self-aware people
the insect offer guy started to look
like their prey
their leathery face plates hardened and
became part of their jaw
their hands and feet developed into
pincers
and their brains evolved intelligence
like many others the bug faces built a
civilization
but they also faced a unique threat
they were attacked by an alien race
little is known about these aliens
because not much survived in the
historical record
but it took an intense series of wars
on the ground and in orbit before the
invaders were defeated
and this traumatic conflict gave the bug
faces
a pathological xenophobic fear
of all other species so when the human
species on other worlds started to reach
out to each other
the bug faces stayed silent and withdrew
from the galaxy
the spacers became even more alien in
the void of space
their fingers extended and split into
tiny grasping limbs
their legs atrophied relying on their
farts to move instead
and in the weightless void of space
their brains expanded
till their every thought was far more
vast and complex than
anything that other humans could
conceive
these asteromorphs spread to every star
system in the galaxy
but they didn't interfere with other
species
the asteromorphs had no need for planets
those ugly balls of dirt and ice and
gravity they stayed in the outer rims of
star systems
silently watching over the galaxy like
strange
alien gods the advanced post-human
species
started making contact with each other
the killer folk
talked with the satyriacs the tool
breeders reached out from their ocean
depths
the modular people and the terra sapiens
joined in
followed by the asymmetric people
saurosapiens and others
they didn't visit each other in person
because the interstellar distances were
too large
but they cooperated by sharing knowledge
and technology
and by keeping watch for alien invasions
they all had found the ruins of the star
people
and the queue and they didn't want to be
attacked and
changed again this alliance of
post-humans lasted for almost 80 million
years with each species expanding to new
worlds
and prospering together the bug faces
never joined them
because they were afraid and xenophobic
but there was one
other advanced species that didn't join
and from them
would come the downfall of the alliance
the ruin haunters were much like other
species twisted by the queue
but on their world the cities of the
star people
hadn't been completely destroyed so the
ruin haunters had
access to remnants of the star people's
technology
which allowed them to advance at a
dangerous pace
the technology developed so fast that
their social and political structures
didn't keep up
and they almost destroyed themselves in
a series of worldwide nuclear wars
this baptism by fire hardened the ruin
haunters
and kind of drove them crazy they
convinced themselves that they
alone were the true descendants and
heirs of the star people
and that only they deserved to reclaim
the legacy
of the golden age of their ancestors so
when the other human species
formed their alliance the ruin haunters
refused to participate
but the ruin haunter's son was rapidly
expanding
and threatened to burn and destroy their
worlds
so the ruin haunters used their super
advanced technology
to abandon their organic bodies and
replace them
with machines they became the gravitals
floating metal spheres that could mold
the environment around them
with gravity fields they were entirely
mechanical but they still had human
minds coded into quantum computers
so they still had human ambitions and
human delusions twisted with neurotic
narcissistic hubris the gravitas started
to exterminate
all other life and the other human
species were
unable to stop them the gravitals would
come to a human world and block out
their sun
behind a vast black sail if the choked
dying world managed to resist they were
finished off with an asteroid
the gravitals didn't hate other species
they just didn't see them as people
and so they wiped them out like one
might
swat a fly all the snake people
the tool breeders terra sapiens and the
others
who had worked so hard to survive were
snuffed out
one by one the only survivors of these
genocides were the shy
and xenophobic bug faces for reasons
unknown
they alone were kept alive and the
gravitals used them as
subjects for biological experimentation
the gravitals twisted them into new
forms so strange that they made the work
of the queue
look tame as well as servants and
labourers they made the subjects into
bizarre art pieces like creatures that
existed only to play the tune of one
particular pop song
on its modified throat and fingers they
made whole
elaborate artificial ecologies of doomed
human flesh
purely for entertainment and curiosity
the gravitas recycled and repurposed
organic life the same way someone might
tinker with computer parts
or recycle trash and for millions of
years
that was how organic life existed in the
machine
empire but not all gravitals saw life
the same way
some religious and philosophical sects
argued that all forms of life had
rights they secretly created human
species who could live and think
freely some gravitas even fell in love
with their human
creations so gravital society became
divided
between the tolerant gravitals who
respected human life
and the hardline conservative
pan-mechanical gravitals
this division threatened to tear the
machine empire apart
so the gravitals looked for a common
enemy to
unify against for millions of years the
gravitals and the asteromorphs had
watched each other nervously
the gravitals on the planets and the
asteromorphs in space
they both were massively powerful and
feared that a war
could destroy them both but in an
attempt to unite
their divided society the gravitals
started
a war with the asteromorphs the
resulting conflict raged for millions of
years
and scarred uncounted stars but in the
end
the asteromorphs triumphed and defeated
the gravitas
toppling their machine empire and the
asteromorphs decided to clean up the
mess that the machines had made
they took the surviving humans who the
gravitals had twisted
and created habitable worlds for them to
live in the asteromorphs played
god seeding life across the galaxy and
the human species
rose reborn as inheritors of the
war-torn worlds
under the watchful eye of the
asteromorphs
the asteromorphs wanted to ensure that
no genocidal [ __ ] would ever conquer
the galaxy again
so they created a smaller simpler
version of themselves called the
terrestrials
to live on the human worlds the
terrestrials played the role of kings
prophets and caretakers guiding their
worlds along
a wise and peaceful path it didn't
always work out too well
sometimes worlds rebelled so the
asteromorphs destroyed them
sometimes the terrestrials were corrupt
and exploited their subjects
but one way or another the human worlds
spread and formed a prosperous galactic
empire the gravitals weren't completely
destroyed
by the asteromorphs it turned out that
it was pretty useful to have
super advanced machines around so the
asteromorphs just disabled their gravity
weapons and
numbed their minds a bit to discourage
rebellion
and they used the gravitals as labourers
to work in dangerous environments
these new machines were given
nanotechnological bodies that could
transform into
any shape they eventually became
citizens of the empire but were often
discriminated against
machines were never fully trusted after
the atrocities of the gravitals
eventually the human asteromorph empire
made contact with life from other
galaxies
including the amphicephalia these weird
snakes that had
snakes inside their snakes apparently
these creatures had had an evolutionary
history
just as long and complex as humanity had
and after all that they'd both been
through the life forms of each galaxy
were finally old enough and mature
enough to meet
peacefully without conflict
this video won't describe all
intergalactic history
the stories are endless how the united
galaxies
re-encountered and defeated the queue
how they
cradled their sons in artificial shells
and crossed space through wormholes
but one moment worth relating is the
rediscovery
of earth a lone researcher located the
birthplace of humanity
where all the asteromorphs and machines
and post-humans could trace their
origins
earth had gone stagnant and feral by
then
an obscure and empty world but after
half a billion years of absence
humans returned to their home world
though both
had changed beyond recognition
i have to end with a confession humans
asteromorphs machines and all their
descendants
are now extinct they've been dead for
a billion years this video is just our
best approximation of their history
based on the
available archaeological evidence we
don't know what killed off the humans
maybe some unimaginably destructive war
maybe their empire broke up and each
world suffered
its own slow private death
some claim that humanity migrated into
some higher plane of existence
we don't know what happened and
ultimately
it doesn't matter the story of humanity
was never about
its end not about its ultimate
domination of galaxies or its
transcendence from reality
being human was always about the daily
lives of people
from the love songs of the carefree
hedonists to the pontifications of the
pterosapians
to the families of the sale people
sharing a meal
grander narratives and absolute ideals
are always what led to humanity's worst
atrocities
the gravitals massacred to reclaim the
past
the q conquered for some fanatical
idealized future
living for some abstract ultimate goal
so often leads to destruction
so when you look on the remains of the
long gone human species
remember that it's the present that
matters not the past or
future what you do today shapes tomorrow
not the other way round so love today
and seize all tomorrows
all tomorrows is a story written and
illustrated by c
m kozaman kozaman is an artist writer
and researcher who does
heaps of fascinating work around
paleontology
history surreal art and all sorts of
stuff
so go check out his website and his
youtube videos
and consider supporting him on patreon
also since this video will probably be
demonetized
consider supporting alt shift x on
patreon as well
we've got more song of ice and fire
videos coming soon
and episode 1 of the alt shift x podcast
is out now
with an interview with the authors of
the expanse so
go check it out thanks for watching and
thanks to the patrons including
sonja berlin wild words alexandra lamaro
varun pramanik najib hashi ashley daniel
colt foster
irish steph and sam's 2006.
cheers